now it can be told history in the making
at the mysterious shangri-la actually
the United States Navy aircraft carrier
Hornet steams westward across the
Pacific
it was 77 years ago this week that 80
American servicemen struck the first
blow against the Japanese mainland in
retaliation for the bombing of Pearl
Harbor closer and closer they approached
enemy control waters
sixteen bombers took off from the deck
of the USS Hornet a first in military
history and bombed targets in Tokyo the
attack known as the Doolittle raid was
planned and led by Lieutenant Colonel
James Doolittle who piloted the lead
bomber in the copilot seat was dick Cole
Cole who died this week at the age of
103 was the last surviving member of
Doolittle's Raiders in 2014 he told
CBS's and a Warner he signed up for the
raid after seeing a message seeking
volunteers the bulletin board said does
anyone want to sign up for a dangerous
mission and you put your name down yeah
why would you do that no other people's
names there maybe it was an inspiration
while Doolittle's raid was not
necessarily a tactical success it did
serve a larger goal the raid on Japan
did very little in terms of physical
damage it did have an enormous
psychological impact on the American
people and for that Cole and his
comrades were awarded the Congressional
Gold Medal in 2014 when just four of
them were still alive
but like so many of the generation that
achieved victory in World War two Cole
did not want more recognition than any
of the others who risked their lives I
don't want to take credit for anything
but doing my job